Now that you know how to statistically decide, whether a sample is different
from a population parameter, the rest of this lesson will be easy. We're going
to use these same concepts to compare two samples that are dependent. They're
dependent when the same subject takes the test twice. This is a Within subject
design. One example, is when each subject, is assigned two conditions in random
order. For example, they're in the control condition, and then they get a
treatment. Or maybe there are two kinds of treatments that they're trying to
test. Another example is if every subject is given a pretest, and then a
post-test. And another example is growth over time, otherwise, known as a
longitudinal study. And then we'll measure the variable for each subject at one
point in time, and then again at another point in time. When we have these
within subject designs, we have paired data. This column of xi's would
correspond to the variable measurements of one condition or of the pretest, or
of some point in time. And then the y values would correspond to a second
treatment, or a post-test, or a measurement at another point in time. And then,
what we want to do is look at the difference between these values. We'll call
this D sub i. And that's just the x values minus the y values. Or it could be
the opposite. We're really just concerned with the absolute difference. Now, we
follow the same procedure as we did before with the one sample t-test, except
we used the values of D.